allez on a regardé les mystères de
l'amour vous le savez on adore cette
série et cette fois ci une scène a
retenu notre attention c'est le malaise
le plus mal joué de l'histoire de la
télé sur un jeu j'aurais jamais pensé
que vous aviez accepté
je suis content si je suis content à
enghien bon anniversaire
moi je sais pas ce que j'ai fait est
qu'ils tournent qui ont dit non ça va
qu'est ce qui t'arrive aidions dit non à
bord du m à y mettre quoi il m'a dit
mattar atlantique doit jouer ça mais
c'est aussi pas il dit dans le cabanon
pas évident jouer à chuter regardez vous
vous savez jouer les mecs ont dormi ou
pas à 3 tu vas t'en dormir tu me
regardes tes paupières sont lourdes très
lourdes
tu n'entends ma voix rien que ma voix tu
dors
moi je veux dire un mot magique tu te
réveilleras venir un mot magique qui te
fera te réveiller c'est dire un mot
magique à 3d qui entendra le mot magique
tu te réveilleras pour l'instant tudor
du nord tu dors tu nord du nord
le mot magique un noeud trois whiskys
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est dans les écoles de théâtre j'en ai
fait une forme de parler de moi j'en ai
fait lui on vous apprend à tomber en
liane
c'est à dire en liane en liane foly aux
lianes ya quoi alors attendez alors ça
donne
alors voilà je vous apprends quelque
chose alors et vous allez simulé un
malaise lors de leurs maux ouais vous
êtes viré
non mais non mais la caméra lorsque ses
15 ans tué dans telle espèce dormal
facebook a laissé ton école à 6,34
millions regarde une déclaration alors
fait de leur beau nom mais tout n'est
pas besoin de regarder une période qui
rien à perdre papeete coup c'est toi qui
concoctait qu'est ce que je vais te dire
le considère pas que c'est de la fiction
de leurs maux oui je dirais je me sens
là
en attendant voilà attend alors attends
attends tu regardes tu m'as dumazy
visite je vais essayer de type de tizé
ouais surtout n'en avoir rien que ma
voix caméra ouais tes paupières sont
lourdes très lourdes à 3 tu dors 1 2 3
du nord dans quelques entendu on
demandera un mot un mot et tu te lèveras
te lèveras mathieu réveille-toi tub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]